[Music]
in California nightmare new California
nightmare
submitted by brownie points the ever
growing rate of California wildfires may
be due to state in federal regulations
not climate change not the rain it's
because they don't want clear trees and
[ __ ] brother we were having so much rain
there's more plants that gets right up
during the summer not just that but
they're saying that California's forests
are now twice as dense as they were 150
years ago my good when the population
was a fraction of today's if this is
unnatural density which is making it
nearly impossible also state and federal
rules make it nearly impossible to lay a
finger on the overgrowth which is
detrimental which is causing a chain
reaction here with the fires and because
it in order to maintain like a
controlled environment you need to do so
we need to cut some trees there yeah in
order to maintain Yosemite they have
controlled fires everywhere and make
like chop about you she recently
actually I found out through this
article after you know we have a new
governor in January oh yeah Gavin oh
yeah wow that's been like years ago so
Jerry Brown Jerry Brown was our last
governor who's our governor right now
even though his name I just
Gavin Newsom yeah Gavin Newsom is that
so anyway so Jerry Brown right he's the
strong guy he's the why we can't have no
straws oh he
and he's why we're not gonna know
shampoo balls in hotels and 2020
what are we supposed to shampoo
ourselves [ __ ] you got to bring your
own [ __ ] again no it looks like American
Psycho - he looks cute oh it's hot like
Christian Bale is he the same guy that
made us not get plastic bags anymore
yes well no that was City Council [ __ ]
but he was down with that is all he was
down with it well he was me who's mayor
I think during some of that so Jerry
Brown Walsh am he right before he
finished his his his term or whatever
he ended up signing bills removing
impediments to controlled burns and
allotting 190 million dollars a year to
improve forest health and fire
prevention so you've been like just by
doing that they're saying in this
article that he pretty much admitted
that california's forest management is
really bad and that's why I like these
fires are pretty much preventable if the
management forest management was was
taken care of but because California is
so careful and like don't touch the
trees don't touch the overgrowth we
don't want to mess up the the habitats
here and like mess with the wild life at
all
that that's actually causing more harm
than good which is causing more co2 to
go in the atmosphere you dumb [ __ ] in
people's houses are burning down and
[ __ ] right but that's what that's what
I'm saying is the fires are [ __ ]
going right in the atmosphere and all
these people who are like well we got to
be super careful bottle trees yeah so
then because of the recent crazy fires
now Pacific Gas and Electric they are
now or like now they're putting more
efforts into having blackouts because
then once you have a blackout then that
that's that's like an effort to calm the
wildfires cuz then if you still got God
as in like turn the lights off for gas
and electricity like once it goes to a
neighborhood it just starts [ __ ] up
the whole thing they're doing rolling
blackouts in certain areas damn I didn't
even know people's like days loose so
they doing on purpose roll your poster
go online what the heck you gotta
evacuate so download all your porn Oh
little-known fact you got your cake you
have any two cents I don't know man I
never had to go through such a [ __ ]
tragic pocalypse block on your street
for like a week for no reason but you
still have cells are your fridge food is
[ __ ] cuz of course not the [ __ ] 4s
no Joe let's say you got no power you
have nothing but a pen and pencil
what do you draw it at your jerk-off pen
and pencil well good thing I'm imparted
to taste man haven't you use your
imagination is trash - Jack sucks close
your eyes I draw a blood like a w-2 so I
don't even think I could jerk off to it
wait can you guys jerk-offs a sensation
of you feeling yourself because that's
what I do know guys are more visual but
you're not a guy it's not helpful I need
to see something going on cuz my ATD
kicks it I guess you do it without
watching anything good my a DVD I think
ixas what did you forget you forget that
we have to be hard
something has to keep us hard you feel
me you can you can rub on the end of
this [ __ ] desk and you be in
Middletown USA and I'm saying I can but
focusing so hard to remember what a
[ __ ] looks like and what my favorite
kind is it's like so much brain power
yeah I mean you're just focusing so hard
to imagine titties and it's all soft now
yeah like [ __ ] man it keeps changing
color yeah where's the work or looseness
it's like well I'm trying to think of a
really tight [ __ ] I'll show them I'm
getting looseness because I'm not not
focusing yeah and then you know like
slap use your wagon [ __ ] rather than
just being present in the moment and
feeling what it feels like guys are
visual so we need to be present with the
eyes with I can't be present as [ __ ]
you got a draw and then once you draw it
like a [ __ ] prison jet sperm bank
thingy like a jackoff material you could
watch that while you peed off like a
[ __ ] and if you dropped it you
can make a bounce in Voyager yeah yeah
yeah in case of a black up for those
yeah but we can't help it as both our
brains yeah I know I bet you'd be trying
you wouldn't be I bet you wouldn't
really she needs visuals she's drawing
titties on the hand she's making a
bouncer we're done yes Dixon Dixon
titties yeah yeah geez bro I'm probably
[ __ ] sculpt something to [ __ ] the [ __ ]
out of hands bro get in there man [ __ ]
the [ __ ] out of a couch when I was a kid
that's all I did when I was 13 was was
it leather those are the best oh here's
what I used to do dawg I used to take
some silk sheets
I put the silk sheets in between the
couch cushions oh my god you're smart
yes where'd you get the sushi from I'm
Thai we have silk sheets just later talk
dirty to the shoes yeah you [ __ ] soft
ass [ __ ] dude I remember after the
things I did to my couch I remember what
my mom we were getting rid of it and my
mom was like oh I'm gonna miss his couch
and I was like if only you knew me too
oh yeah it's just kind of a natural
thing I think there comes a time in a
boy's life where he experiments on soft
things meanwhile all over the hell my
friends gangbang the couch yes poor
couch never saw it coming except what if
his always what was going dad was
licking the couch yeah he was talking to
me in the couch while we took it from
both sides yeah
you know like young boys are always
window shopping for things they can
stick their dick in like Oh everything
this month this feels like a good yeah
my mom got a new couch me and my friends
we all took a look at that chasing couch
with the chaise lounge
and we're like we [ __ ] made wildfires
turn into sex right well cuz it's fiery
do my friends and I we were all taking
that cops from both sides and we were
high-fiving each other yeah yeah [ __ ]
Eiffel Tower about that irony about
California being well californee likes
to pretend like it's doing something
that's the whole thing it makes people
yeah it's a very mismanaged state that
sounds like the tree huggers are the
ones causing the fires cuz we're not
gonna cheers our politicians they all
they care about is pleasing people right
in people if they get angered or
whatever they say this whatever is gonna
get the votes and it's not the most
effective thing to do but then they just
say and so a lot of people going [ __ ]
y'all vote for you it's like people were
anti hunting yeah and they don't know
that if you let these animal populations
go wild they actually [ __ ] with the
environment but they think they're being
super in a mentally conscious by not
killing animals yeah it's a same
mentality it's like well I have the best
intentions it doesn't matter if it
actually is good yeah like there's a
wild horse population in Nevada and
every year they round up a few and then
they uh you know they basically catch
them and then they have this whole
program where they sell them off and
there's a lot of people that don't like
that but if they didn't do that what the
wild horses will do is they'll eat all
the vegetation and then they'll end up
pretty much killing themselves off mmm
it's like Thanos was right okay no you
gotta you guys seen it no you know what
happens yeah he snaps and then like okay
so that was the last one now do you not
know that all the [ __ ] memes out
there and [ __ ] nobody anybody who the
most confused man every you just see a
bunch of people getting dusted all over
the place and you're like I don't know
this one
everyone turns to dust is okay let's not
talk about it for this guy he has no
[ __ ] clue what's happening he was
right
wait so you plan on watching yep okay
okay well basically if there's if
there's if there's too much of us we're
just gonna you know it [ __ ] up the
natural system mode and the way things
work you know which is already happening
yeah but I think the genius is in the
technology they're gonna solve it all
dude look at the plastic max thing right
10 15 years ago it was we shouldn't use
plastic bags we should use paper bags
paper bags like because the plastic
sound phat Carius or whatever and then
it went to oh no we should use plastic
bags not paper bags cuz we're gonna save
the trees and then now it's like we
shouldn't use any bags at all bring your
own bags
[ __ ] reusable bags but then they find
out that reasonable bags that carry
diseases easily really yeah because
people keep reusing them and they put
all kinds of produce in them and the
[ __ ] yeah it's muscle wash it up just
stop trying to control people people
just a washer you reusable them down
they also found out that the plastic
thing is [ __ ] because a lot of
people were reusing their plastic things
take a kitty litter and all kinds of
different things they were using it for
trash they're using it for bathroom
trash bags and [ __ ] yeah we do that yes
so people were actually using them
consciously and so this whole like we're
saving things because the plastic is not
even real y'all use your grocery bags to
take out a trash bags and stuff
everything and then you use them again
for gross I can you throw it away
correct absolutely
sometimes as a shower cap to you guys
ever use so use them for overalls when
you're a kid I was maybe that little no
like you build with the holes at the
bottom you put your foot in it's really
just sound like a diaper to me I don't
see the overall Geodude have a trash bag
like the whole like the [ __ ] hefty
ones of the yellow handles
yeah she was doing that at six years old
huh she still dresses like that
[Music]